it's extraordinarily important that we  not be fooled by this Redemption tour of  sorts that Marjorie Taylor green now is  on her perspective is now that Kevin  McCarthy is Speaker I voted for the  speaker Republicans are in power I can  either go the way of being kind of one  of these agitators like Lauren bobert  who she's very much in a war with at  this point in time or I can be cozy with  power  I can get back on committees  and that's very appealing to Marjorie  Taylor green she is clearly desperate  for power and part of this may even be  starting to think about continuing to  Lobby to be Donald Trump's vice  presidential running mate the other  thing and this is not about oh  everyone's a fascist that's not what I'm  saying but when we think about  authoritarianism and fascist wannabes  and dictator wannabes  fascists will often do these rewriting  of their own history realignments these  sort of redemption tours if you allow  them to do it